for the tampa bay rays it will be
right-hander michael walka
making his fifth appearance fourth start
on the season
hits it hard and it's under the glove of
a diving joey wendell and a leadoff
single here in the first from arcana so
that breaks a little for nine stretch
for canna
a popper short right lao
is out there and makes the catch
fly ball the other way rosarina
is there waiting and he'll make the
catch and back to first heads cannon
2-2 he got him he struck him out to
retire the side
had him out in front on the change
bottom half of any one coming no score
we'll be taking on that man right there
frankie montos fifth start of the season
second career start against tampa first
pitch to kevin kirmeyer he strokes it
toward the corner
into that corner it goes
piscotty plays the carom and kirmar's
already on his way to third with the
triple and the throw there was a bit
wide
keermeyer first pitch a three base hit
i like that it's down in the lower third
toss knocks it down picks it up throws
to first and kiermeier has to stay at
third
randy rosarina with the infield up
ground ball third that'll get the run
home comes up on machine he
makes no play on it the rays get the
first run of the game
shift is on for austin meadows who hits
one high
in the air shallow right
where piscotti waits and he's got it
julie wendell bounces one toward lowry
lowry grabs it and throws out wendell
and that will do it run for the raise
they lead one nothing
smokes one what a diving play by lao
gets up throws wide of first
and moreland's going to be aboard be
careful here
and that one is smoke to center and
that's a base hit
murphy squared that one up and these
have two on and nobody out
broken bat that's gonna work dropped
into left field for a base hit
and the aids are gonna have the bases
loaded as moreland stops at third
and now these will try to capitalize
with female machine
taps this one slowly toward first
suzuka's gonna grab it himself and step
on the back that will get
a run home so the first rbi is in the
books for
vimal machine and this game is tied at
once so a very productive out
this one by the mound and allows there
to make the pickup
canters out of there and out of that
bases loaded situation
raids give up only one
up the right side that ball is headed
into the corner
biscotti will go in afterwardsugo
turning on the speed and he's in there
in second with a stand-up double
it's yoshi turning on a fastball mid to
upper
[Music]
he 90s this one up biscotti hustling
in and piscotty of those three ace
players right there piscotty's the only
one who saw it
and thank goodness one of the three saw
one and two the count to olson who would
have fly ball to left field in the first
goes down and gets this one and he's got
a base hit that's five hits
now for the athletics off waka
his jam popped it up
and who's going to make the catch the
diaz
is there to grab it finally
oh two to cure meyer and he swings and
misses at the high fastball so frankie
matas does quick
work of kevin kiermeier this time and
that's the first strikeout for botox
[Music]
there's a base hit into right lao aboard
with one out here in the third
swing gonna miss he struck him out so
meadow strikes out couple of strikeouts
for montos
in the bottom of the third league east
is is a mystery in a lot of ways right
now murphy is out on
strikes three pitches
back into center field karemeier is
going to go all the way to the wall
he'll leap
and he makes the
catch keemer all the way to the wall
as he turned reaching up with a little
leap and grabs that one
for out number two
three pitches he strikes out joey
wendell
there's a line drive that's a fair ball
up the right field side into the corner
beyond the bullpen
tatugo's gonna go to third it'll be a
double
for mejia they get the ball back into
the plate
and he got him fastball and phillips
strikes out
the raise strand a pair we're moving to
the fifth it's a one-one game
a little tapper with the pick up and the
throw he throws it away
and loud's going to head down to second
maybe more that ball rolled
back of the bullpen mound wow kind of
hesitated for a moment
aussie timmons was pointing to second
and he walks him
and he got him and it was a splitter had
a little
fading movement away from meadows and
toast gets the big strikeout he gets
meadows for the second time
tonight oh for two then he grounds this
one right to lower he throws to
first bob toss gets out of the jam so
the rays strand a pair and we are
through five it's a 1-1 game
smoked fair down the first base line
olson rounds the bag he's going to
hustle for second the throw coming in
it's a little bit off-line and olson has
a lead off double here in the sixth
so here is mitch moreland
and he hits a fly ball to left field the
rosarina
settling underneath it and then
kiermeier comes out of nowhere
the throw to the plate is not in time
olson just gets in and the a's lead 2-1
though the angle probably wasn't much
better a stronger throwing arm
the quarterback of the outfield he's
going to take charge and you can see him
calling for the ball the entire time
well the count to francisco mejia
shoots it back into center field that
has some carry
going to be over the head of l'oreal and
off the wall and that's going to be a
long
single all right well he's at first or
two down for grant phillips
there's a fly ball hit well back into
center lorianno's gonna look up that
baby's
out of here home run from red phillips
on a 2-2 pitch and the range will take
the lead
how about brett phillips
good swing looped
and that's a fair ball brown didn't
leave the box
so he's going to get a single i was
watching brown's reaction and he just
didn't move
[Music]
ground ball back to the hill grabbed by
thompson
halfway to first and the toss in time
seventh inning stretch time of the ball
park
as here is randy rosarina slicing one
down the right field line if
this one heading toward the corner it's
a fair ball off the wall brown
plays it on a couple of bounces and
randy go ahead in the second base
with his fourth double in the season the
two outs runner at second base and
that'll bring up joey wendell
and there it is he punches it through
the left side
throws gonna be cut off the rays will
score the run
throw back to first and wendell's back
in there but rosarina
comes around to score and the rays
going old for 26 within in scoring
position
before joey wendell comes through to
make it a 4-2 raised lead
he's come up against diego castillo and
sean murphy will lead it off
oh and that one is belted to deep left
field and
that baby is go 454
feet is the estimated distance of that
home run by murphy
and they may have shortchanged them a
little bit four to three
tampa bay he's three and two with
chapman
and a swing at a miss he strikes him out
came back with a slider and the rays win
it
it's a 4-3 final a run scores on the
home run
and the ninth heading and the rays win
this one
4-3